get out now you
leave while you can run bro
leave
go now get out
[Music]
my guy pretty like a girl and he got
five stories to tell i see both sides
like chanel see on both sides like
chanel
what song is that
are you asking me i'm asking everyone oh
that's not going to start episodes from
now i'm just going to sing random lyrics
and hope everyone can figure out the
song i hope they i hope they [ __ ]
realize who he is frank
who was the last one that i did
i don't remember the last one spiraling
up just like a rich [ __ ] staircase
[Music]
[ __ ] everything about the day wouldn't
the dad say
you know what since i want to see you
are working in squarespace
i know this song i can't remember jake
oh man
my life
i remember how the thingy went i know
how the cadence goes or like the temple
goes right yeah
i was never getting that i was never
gonna
um this is episode
111 i believe so
sorry this is episode 111
and your bubba bubba boys j money and
flaming flakes
[Laughter]
um
we're here to serenade your earlobes and
your eardrums
with the with the sweet mellow base of
these rhythm and soul voices you know
the vibes um
and guys before
before we get into anything too heavy
um let's play a game oh hit me that's to
wake me up it's going to live in my life
you're going to get angry oh my god best
accent game oh god
i'm terrible i know you're guessing i
said you're going to get angry
what's up for the [ __ ] best acting game
so i choose an accent then you choose an
accent
and we'll go back and forth oh
god okay yeah
yeah so you choose an accent for me and
she's not for you or um well both dudes
will both do all accents okay then we'll
decide
equally who we think is better who we
think is better okay and then um they
will decide they'll just they'll let us
know
yeah
all right cool we know i'm gonna be
terrible first accent
you probably beat me in this one first
accent essex
s6
i know it sounds like doesn't
necessarily mean i'll beat you in it i
haven't got an essex accent i don't even
know what it sounds like uh i kind of do
it's kind of like cottony right
kind of yeah
um
[ __ ]
the thing sorry to it no no go on go on
the thing with accents i feel like i'm
more likely to be able to mimic once i
hear as opposed to thinking about the
accent and then saying it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
because i know when essex accent is
meant to sound like but i can't remember
if for me i can when i think of an
accent i always think of one word okay
one word usually it's
the sound what the name of the place
sounds like in their accent and that
triggers it for me okay that's a good
that's a good way to trick your brain
yeah that's how i usually do it so like
in my head it would be like um
like
scottish scottish scottish yeah and then
like did you peel
[Music]
each
e leave a peel there's always a trigger
word yeah
and then like essex so what would it be
like dagenham
dagenham stagger them
um
it's more like yeah it's more like a
cockney smile you want mate white white
mate white man from dirty dog in a
minute
[Laughter]
have you ever seen on tick tock where
they do like um
where they do like um english accents
yes oh there's one it's always like a
cockney or satin accent and then they
try and read it out yeah yeah yeah they
spell out what it would sound like an
english accent yes so i want a bottle of
water i see what is it i want a
water
i want a bottle of water
i saw one chick she's american she was
like ah you guys the british accent is
so sexy i've heard so many people try
and fake it and blah blah blah but i'm
going to show you what it is big man i
saw that one
all right my painting here what you
saying she goes road and he does so i
saw that joe the brunette yeah yeah i
saw it sweet off on it i saw it sweetie
off on it all right cause
but yeah we'll make it harder right we
have to say a certain
sentence in that that's perfect okay
that's perfect i have to say certain
sentence in that accent right so we've
done exit yeah you choose one
so you choose one of them what to say
um okay german oh my god
and you have to say [ __ ] now that's
horrible say hi my name is james and i'm
alcoholic
i don't know german accents at all
that's what i'm saying bro i have to say
german if i could hear the german accent
i should or i may be able to imitate a
little bit
but then
i do i do annie that's german right or
austrian austrian same [ __ ]
it's someone
[Laughter]
i'm james
hi
hi i'm james and i'm an alcoholic
[Laughter]
all right you going now same thing i'm
feeling
i'm alcoholic
hi
i'm fuhad i think
i'm food
hi i'm
and i'm an alcoholic yeah
all right swede right let me go um
i'll make it easier we'll go liverpool
okay
and you have to say um
i like licking lovely lollipops
i like licking lovely lollies lovely
lollipops i like licking
[ __ ] looking lollipops
[ __ ]
clicking
lovely lollipops
if you peel
i like okay
e
i like uh you know
i like licking lovely lollipops you know
you know you know you know i like
[ __ ] uh lovely lollipops
you know it's so um oh what's his name
jamie carragher yeah yeah
he says you know all the time you know
you know
uh you know you know i like licking
lovely [ __ ] lollipops [ __ ]
lollipops
your [ __ ] thoughts
okay all right cool your turn i say
oh no country
australia oh [ __ ] me
this country it's actually pretty decent
you've done a couple of show dances
before
um australia and say um
she sold seashells on the seashore
[ __ ]
all right australia
i'm from australia g'day
g'day little river
i'm from australia and she sells [ __ ]
she
she sells [ __ ] seashells on this
[ __ ] seashore
[Laughter]
that's hilarious
that is [ __ ] hilarious
oh my days
oh all right same thing go you got this
g
australia i'm warm bro i need to open a
window
my throat is horse
australia g'day mate good day mate
australia just trying to
breathe in the yeah yeah australia
new south wales that that
you got it you got it
adelaide
you got that adelaide
where what's that spot bola one go what
there's a spot called like bollywood or
bologna really i'm sure there's a spot
in australia called like body wonk or
golly wong or something like that i've
never hope not
not going to work there's like bologna
sorry stupid like that i don't know um
what did i say to say oh she sells cj
yeah on the seashore
australia australia could mate good day
mine [ __ ] um she sells [ __ ] uh
seashells on the [ __ ] seashore mate
[Laughter]
okay all right cool
um next
accent let's go for
french okay
saying
saying
don't touch me on the bottom
french
french french
[Music]
don't touch me on the bottom don't touch
me on the bottom
it doesn't really
keep
[Laughter]
wow that was good that was really good
never sounded like nonsense
that was really good i don't think i'm
gonna be able to do it okay
don't touch me on the bottom
uh francais
francais
[Laughter]
uh
don't touch me on the bottom
don't touch me
don't touch it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's hilarious brother oh brav all
right cool that's french your turn
you'll turn your attention oh okay let's
go we'll do two more each all right gang
um let's go
let's go like southern american like
jesus jesus christ
and let's go
i like big butts and i cannot lie you
other brothers can't deny oh [ __ ] me
texas
not necessarily okay southern america
all right it's of course cool
southern america like
right i'm from austin texas
louisiana
from louisiana down to down to bayou
i'm from louisiana
i'm from down to buy you and i like some
gumbo
and i like big butts and brother i can't
deny
your wedding's character i like it i
like it you went into character because
i
i have to say the name of the place
um louisiana
and goddamn
louisiana um texas texas louisiana um
goddammit i like big butts
and i cannot lie
you are the brothers
can deny bro
you sounded like a like two steps off on
obama
i just heard it nothing
i like
big birds
and i cannot lie
you were
you other brothers
you can't deny canned dinner
all right cool right
let's go with that from me i didn't like
that one
yeah it was cool
let's go with
i'm trying i didn't know what [ __ ]
countries there are out there man
yadi
okay yeah
um this is gonna reflect poorly on me
this is gonna reflect poorly on me
because you'll beat me on this one i
can't do yardly accident to save my life
it depends on the center of the brother
all right cool
why'd you take so long to get the
chicken
yard
hold on
i'm laughing because you're doing it and
i i realized
i saw the point where you realize what
you're about to have to do
and you're the thing about that like
just this side of your mouth went
[Laughter]
thinking [ __ ]
[Laughter]
why did you take so long to get the
chicken yeah
all right
[ __ ] i hate that i'm going first
[Music]
cucumber
um
are you rude boy away takes all i'll get
me bombaclat chicken
i'm surprised
that was good fair enough that was good
fair enough i appreciate it [ __ ] i'm
fixed now
all right cool what's that why take so
long to get chicken
oh my brother
oh it takes so long to get chicken huh
hey yo my brother oh my brother are you
oh my oh you're my youth
i owe my oh wait
a chicken now wait take someone to get
me [ __ ] chicken
chicken all right all right all right
cool your turn your turn this is your
last one and i got one more i think okay
we'll go italian
sake food i don't know what it sounds
like
it's gonna know what that sounds like
we'll go italian and we'll go
why would you snap the spaghetti in two
it needs to stay straight okay
cool that's like there's a tick tock
about diana yeah
in two it needs to be straight
italiano
away snapped spaghetti into it needs to
be straight
alora
hello that was good that was good that
was actually good all right cool um
italian italian italiano
james
and why you snapped the uh spaghetti in
two
it's neat uh terrible terrible that was
alright you weren't too far off nah nah
nah
nah i lost it there i lost it there
italiano italiano
uh
ciao james
why you are snapped spaghetti in two it
has to stay straight
that wasn't bad that wasn't bad that
wasn't no no no don't beat yourself up
it wasn't bad don't beat yourself up
that wasn't bad at all
i think that mine was too emphasized
mine was too
cartoonish
you said chad james that was good
right um
to finish off let's go with
mexican
no no no we'll go japanese
okay you go japanese yeah
and you have to say
you bring dishonor
you bring dishonor
with this [ __ ]
you bring this honor with this [ __ ]
japanese
japanese
you bring this honor with this [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] you bring dishonor with this
[ __ ] japanese japanese
okay
james
you bring this one into the sheet
james
you bring this on with this
[ __ ] that was shocking i didn't even
know if that was japanese that was
hilarious sure that was far from
i'm sure that's uh far from wow um i've
heard better but that was all right
you wanted that you went with an older
man
slow paced yeah man yeah man yeah all
right cool gang all right [ __ ] hell
guys welcome to the episode
if you're not a buyer already
patreon.com
shits and gigs head on over there
catches every thursday talking up the
most um if you're still with us thank
you very much
i have no idea how long that took
a little time
but yeah
jumping over to patreon if you're
watching us on youtube make sure you
bump into that like button and you give
that subscribe a little
um turn on your notifications please
and uh make a couple friends in the
comments
if you must um or enemies let's see some
fights no one ever fights in the
comments i want to see a scrap
i want to see people go blow for blow
they do more on tick tock oh god
they go
bro i've seen i've seen some of our tick
tocks with like 130 replies
[Laughter]
bro ridiculously the back-to-backs are
silly yeah yeah but okay cool so yeah
um running over to our instagram run on
over to our twitter
if you're listening to this um audibly
uh make sure you subscribe to the
channel so you get those automatic
downloads guys help us with the
algorithm any way you can please would
be much appreciated and as always
message us comment whatever you need to
do email us uh to send in your am i the
[ __ ] just if you just want a little
bit of advice or just want our opinion
on whatever or something that uh we're
going to start doing reaction vids
actually
so this is uh breaking news um high
demand
high demand two two bits of news
actually on high demand first of all
we are going to be um
doing some reaction vids in the near
future as um that's been
requested a lot
um and secondly
our other thing that's been requested a
lot has been a spotify playlist
yes i remember you talking to me about
that spotify playlist we're going to be
doing those two in the near future so
keep an eye out for those
i just want to stop for a second
and talk about
manscaped
you already know you already know you
want to hear this
you want to hear this
then you need manscapes
you need the smooth buttery goodness
of well-shaven pubes and you don't want
any nicks you don't know scars yeah
you want your scrote ready fam
and the only way you're gonna get that
is through
the 4.0 generation
you can go for the lawn mower 4.0 you
can go for the performance package 4.0
you can go through all of the 4.0s as
long as there's a four a point i don't
know you're on the right track
so
i said you should go for the performance
they sent us our performance package the
other day
[Music]
and you wouldn't believe what's involved
you pop open the thing like this it's
got it's got a little rippy rippidy dip
there you go
wrap it like that and then as you open
it it pops out and just like on um
just like on pulp fiction where they
open the box it's just gold
exactly that's exactly i'm not even
joking this time that's exactly what the
landscape box does i'm not even playing
anyone who's got it can vouch when you
open it in shine's gold
bro you got your crop preservers your
ball toners big man
you got your your lawnmower 4.0 just
chilling there ready to be gripped
ready
bro and then you got your boxes just
folded
they they they they they feel like
egyptian silk
and when you slap them on when you when
you get you freshly shave it yeah yeah
you put your ball toner on and your
deodorant and you you wiggle your body
in it and you hear that
you know you're ready to yeah yeah
you're ready to clap
you're ready to clap
so guys
if you want to get involved
and you live anywhere on planet earth
then the code is sng sierra november
golf
it's called sng
at manscape.com
and if you want free shipping you slap
in that sng
if you want 20 off as well some people
don't want 20 off but if you do
slap in that sng manscape.com sng 20 off
free shipping worldwide performance
package 4.0 let's get it let's
back to the episode come on
um any more housekeeping notes i don't
know
i don't think so just stay locked in
thank you for keep rocking with us
really
that's about it thank you as always and
without further ado we have uh
um today's fun fact actually isn't fun
it's just a fact
okay it's just a fact bro all right guys
i ready the other day i was like wow
okay this is the headline
california dad
murdered his toddlers in front of in
start again california dad murdered his
toddler infant over fears that he has
the serpent's dna
as in satan the serpent fam
all right sorry go i know you've got
questions sorry i'll finish that's a
vague heading
a california man influenced by q19 and
illuminati conspiracy theories confessed
to killing his two young children with a
spear fishing gun
in mexico because they inherited the s
the serpent dna from his wife and were
growing they were going to grow into
monsters
his name is matthew taylor coleman he's
40 years old he made the statement yeah
he made the statements to federal
investigators after being arrested at
the border in the wake of of monday's
double phillicide court documentation i
don't know what filler side is maybe
like a young homicide yeah i'm assuming
like pedophile filler side sounds like
probably something to do with kids kids
yeah maybe
coleman was reported missing by his wife
on august the 7th after he left his
santa barbara home with his
ten-month-old daughter 10 month old
daughter and two years old son without a
car seat for the infant and took them to
risarito according to the documents he
allegedly shot them dead through their
chest with a spear guard and was
arrested by customs and border patrol as
he tried to re-enter the us only two
days later
the border the border cops observed what
appeared to be blood on his paperwork in
a vehicle and the mexican police found
the young bodies matching the
description of coleman's kids in a ditch
according to the documents
the suspect waved his miranda rights and
told the feds he believed his children
were going to grow up to be monsters so
he had to kill them he was charged with
foreign murder of us nationals and was
slated to appear in the la court
wednesday and this was only on august
11. so this was a few weeks ago this is
a real thing that happened a few weeks
ago you mean some of this didn't happen
in 1985. this happened a few weeks ago
brother this year to be fair said it
influenced by q and on so obviously
didn't happen back then but wow a spear
fishing
gun bro
a two-year-old and a 10 month old baby
bread drip
how did he lose his mind so much i found
these are the only details i've got
that's why i said it's not a fun fact
it's just a fact
big man just the fact it reminded when i
read that because obviously i read it a
couple days ago and i was gonna say on
here but it reminded me of that um show
i told you about that watched on netflix
where
um
he killed his
wife and two kids
and
they were coming back from uh she came
back from a holiday the friend was
trying to find the wife knocking on the
door blah blah and he came back from
work a very oblivious you know where's
my wife and he threw the kids in the oil
drum through the kids in the old drum it
reminded me of that
it reminds me how do people how do
people live their whole life normal
manage to have a family a house a job a
wife a car
and then lose their [ __ ] so much that
they kill their own kids with a spear
fishing gun spear fish in mexico
i can't even imagine the velocity i wish
that trump that would have propelled
into their chest
bro both of them did i hope you had more
than one arrow i hope you're more than
one arrow because
and then man
and then again no no no no no no no no
how did you lose it so much i don't know
how i don't know because that's not fam
on top of that let me show you the
picture that they use to
explain this thing obviously you know to
put like cover photos and stuff
that's his cover photo
that's a normal family my g
oh for christ sake
for christ's sake
wild right
i need to know what happened for the
audio listeners it's just him his wife
and two kids smiling at the camera when
they look like they want to ski and trap
they look like they're on holiday having
the greatest time that's literally the
photo they use for the caption of this
story oh man it was posted by the new
york post as well
crazy right
that's ridiculous crazy imagine
witnessing that no imagine being all
right imagine being in mexico you're for
some reason you're on the border or like
close to the border where in some
deserted area i don't know
tijuana i don't know where that is where
enjoys around there
you're you're driving you're actually
like you're a farmer or something you're
in the woods you're in this this
terrain
you're chilling now you're doing your
work you're doing whatever you want to
do all you hear is
but you're
you're you familiarize yourself with
that sound but you know there's no sea
or water around you so why am i hearing
a spear fishing gun thing
you hear it again
fam you just like you search round and
you can see a man
dragging the spear fisher gun back and
you're like what's going on and you seen
dip what do you do
obviously because he left the youths
there
so i can see the corpses there
oh oh you mean do i go over there or
just oh my god i'm asking what do you do
you've not seen the corpses but you hear
the gun you're suspicious but you hear
it again
and then i see him drive off you see him
peel off you don't see him peel off but
you see a car peel off
and i know there's a spear fishing you
know that's spiffing spear fishing gun
you know there's no water around you
cool i'm definitely going over there
okay 100 i'm going over there
um
and then i'll probably bring my gun
i'll probably be my gun just in case so
he might have been maybe he said i'll
probably bring mike i know if we're well
he's already got a gun in mexico that's
jokes continue said yeah if i live in
two one i've got guns
um i'll probably be my gun because i
think
he might have been one of the good guys
he might have been shooting like el
chupacabra or something like that
he might have been shooting something
bad true you know i've been my gun over
there
yeah yeah i have a look if i see two
babies dead on the floor
and my mouse peeled off
one million percent bro i'm sprinting to
my pickup truck
i need to follow him i need to catch up
and i need to follow him because he's
done for
100 i couldn't see that kids
kids
couldn't see that couldn't see that
speaking of i've got a story for you
it's a regurgitated story nothing to do
with me okay but i've got a story that
happened to um a guy
on a pod that runs a pod that i listen
to okay
so this guy
check this [ __ ] out
this guy was driving down the um this
happened like two weeks ago
this guy was driving so basically like i
said is one of the hosts of a podcast
that i like to listen to
he was basically driving down the road
with his missus one day
um and he saw like
kind of like a like a crack he's seen an
accident on the side of the road okay
and he was just going to drive past it
and typically he would drive past it as
most people would sorry where's his base
so i could like pitch it so it's in
america okay uh in just in l.a okay so
he's in l.a he's driving down the
highway
sees a car has crashed into like a lorry
okay a big truck
and um like on oncoming traffic hurting
or like on common traffic so like um
he's seen um
i think
i'm assuming so say he's going this way
if he's facing forward the truck is
facing forward and the car is facing
against it okay so it's
yeah
nose
to
and as he's driving past he's looked and
he can see like a five-year-old kid so
the car's like um yeah the car's like
they're normal
crushed and you can see a five-year-old
kid on the roof
going like this to traffic
so my man says what
pulls up and his girlfriend what the
[ __ ] are you doing what the [ __ ] you
doing get back in the car and that's it
there's a you jumping on the car yeah by
himself yeah runs over there says do you
work one what's going on yeah yeah yeah
and he says my brothers are inside
he looks inside
and there's a two-year-old and a
four-year-old
in the car strapped into the car they
can't get out
so he has to bust through the window
this is in the this is like a dual
carriage or something yeah he has to
bust through the window
and you can see there's gas leaking out
of the car
um and he said actually
just as he was running towards the u
that was going like this he saw a man
running across the highway
on the other side who got hit by a car
but then like got up and kept running
running away so he said what the [ __ ]
yeah prior to him seeing the crash no
he's seen the crash has he's pulled up
yes yes yes yes yes got out the car
because he's seen this he looks to the
other side and sees the man running off
oh my god the man gets hit by a car gets
up and like limps off and keeps running
off he looks at my man he's seen the you
going like this he looks at my man seen
get hit by a car and run off and say
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah runs off
says my brothers are inside yeah
smashes the window
drags the kids
and is the truck drivers helping them as
well okay starts dragging one of the
kids out
goes to grab the other kid and the other
kid's like mommy mommy mommy mommy mommy
mommy mommy mommy so he's like what's
going on and he's like he says the drug
driver is there anyone else in the car
he says yeah i think there's someone in
the front he looks in the front the
mom's dead
her brain splattered all over the
dashboard that was dead
and the kids don't know the kids in the
back they don't know their mom's dead so
he has to like cover the kids eyes and
[ __ ] to get him out and he says to the
driver like put a blanket over the mum
or something the kids can't see that
um
so now we've got like a six or four year
old two-year-old
um so we saved their life everything
like that
went into the deeper details found out
from the police like what happened and
stuff like that apparently
the um
the dad
was the man that was running across the
road because as soon as you said i think
maybe it's the truck driver i assumed it
was a truck driver off the bat
wow
the apparently the dad
got the whole family in the car one day
got him on the road
um on a drive and was like
we're all going to heaven today
the whole family's going to heaven today
he tried to kill the whole family drove
into the truck on purpose went on like
uncommon drove into uncommon traffic and
tried to kill her family
and the only person killed was his wife
[ __ ]
bro [ __ ]
how crazy is that that's insane what
goes through people's minds man bro
people are off off their head kids bro
three three little kids
why don't
why don't people just talk [ __ ] out why
do if you wanna if you wanna dump
yourself if you wanna die go and die
yourself
go away why are you trying to ruin
everything for everyone
man's ruined families now bro
i just don't understand the human psyche
to the point where you can be
cognizant enough
to like i said have a house have a job
have a family have everything going
normal for you but you're so cracked
that you're like
oh on saturday i'm gonna get the whole
family in the car and i'm gonna kill us
all
i'm definitely gonna do that and you
have that in your head you're that
cracker you have that in here but you
can run your life normal for the rest of
it
and you actually do it you actually get
everyone in and say we're all dying
today just so you know and you actually
go through with it
psychologically i bro it doesn't make
any sense to me i don't know how that's
the thing
family i promise you if i'm in a passy
i'm a messenger saying oh we're all
going to heaven today
i'm
i'm having yanking the stereo or yank in
the handbrake oh handbrake's going up
straight away because i don't know what
you're talking about you're probably
gonna get a box in your mouth as well
cause you're chatting [ __ ] bro you're
chatting sh you can't kill me under you
if i'm sitting there
if i'm sitting there
and i'm here in and we're on the road
we're driving
and then i'm hearing okay cool role play
it's me and you
we're in a gay relationship
we've got three adopted utes from
nicaragua in the back six four and two
you're such an idiot but yeah
you're tapped
of course it's me of course you're
tapped yeah and you get us all in the
car and say let's go for a sunday drive
yeah
the you already know the rest of the
story yeah yeah and we'll play it off
and see how it goes right
action right
action
james grab the kids let's get in the car
man um sunday roast usual spot you know
how i like it
you know i thought i treat the family
today cheating thought and cheating the
family today granny utes let's go
what are you saying
gang gang cool man tree cool love a
sunday treat i know i might earn
yourself a little sunday treat
gang
so we grabbed chris kyle and caleb get
chris carl caleb get him in the car guys
come on get in the car guys
vamanos vamos vamos vamos gris
let's go speeding on the highway and our
cruising cruising cruising
let's music's playing
it's five in the morning
yeah
pretty rigged ricky in the back
everyone's just living life everyone's
lavish unless you don't even know what
they're [ __ ] um
just chilling having a good time gang
cool
i'm coming driving now driving
chilling chilling chilling i just turned
and look at you
don't look at me like that first and
foremost
james um
babes
i think we're all going to heaven today
like
metaphorically because the the roast is
going to be so good
um
i mean that would have been nice
but
that's not what i mean but that's not
what i mean
what do you mean
i'm taking us all out
pardon
i'm taking car's speeding up i'm taking
us all out
who's us
me you chris caleb and the other one
i'm taking us all out why
i've had enough
i've had enough of all of you
are you [ __ ] serious oh i'm 100
serious 100 i've had enough
yes i've had enough of what
you the kids the lies
the late nights
the stress
i've had enough i've been trying to talk
to you for months james you don't want
to listen to me i've had enough big man
i can't hear you because your head's all
the way up your own [ __ ] ass oh yeah
yeah i swear
[ __ ] slag
bro fam
i'm yanking it i'm yanking a handbrake
i'm yanking it as soon as we come to a
stop
vaseline
you want to see heaven so bad get a [ __ ]
out of the car
you want to see heaven i'm clicking my
nails off
you want to see heaven get a [ __ ] out of
the car
and i ain't talking about the barn
either
fam [ __ ] it oh i couldn't that screw
i couldn't fake i actually felt the fear
in my chest
i felt the fear in my chest
that's real-life g-force i could have i
couldn't firm that bro
nah man went into a truck bro
imagine being the truck driver
imagine it was trucker dave probably was
trucker dave jesus the truck his
livestock got murk that day livestock
man couldn't do no trades on the border
whatsoever he was livid
wow
smack bang into a truck
wow everyone survived finding it from
the mum that's you that [ __ ] like that
man the one that cared about them
it drives me insane same g it drives me
insane kill your damn self kill your
damn self man so now the three years
have to live with the fact that they're
probably never going to see the mo
they're 100 never gonna see their pops
again one million percent i'm never
going to see their mom again
and
the two young kids probably have no
recollection of what happened whereas
the older kid that was on the thing yeah
he knows he knows what happened but he
doesn't know why they're gonna grow up
and find out that's a trauma man yeah so
i think um
what my man did obviously he's got a lot
of pee and a lot of influence
they had a gofundme yeah for the mom's
funeral and it was 30 grand yeah that
they were trying to raise
and from the support that my men got
from mention on the pod
and they got like 70 80 grand okay and
then he's going to try and do
he's a stand-up comedian so i think he's
going to try and do some shows
and charity shows and obviously dedicate
all the money to the kids so obviously
growing up they'll be looked after
college all this stuff and they can
start to pattern what are the odds
what the odds of someone like him see
but then again
you said it was on like a motorway kind
of thing i'm surprised like only a
couple people well he said after
everything was said and done he looked
back there was bare people outside their
cars but they were like is there
anything we can do like what's going on
and he was a big man you're 10 minutes
what do you mean is there anything you
can do and there must have been better
people that drove past yeah of course
that's what i mean about the episode a
little while ago let's talk about the
the the
the misses that um killed herself in my
apartment block yes yes yes yes yes
it sucks but there's just not enough
people that are like
like see something like a fight or
flight yeah like let's see something odd
we see so many like crazy you see so
many car crashes every day
and stuff like that it's just it's weird
that you like so many people will just
drive past
and just see i i personally don't think
i'll drive past if i saw you like this
and there's only ever been one time
in my life where i've seen a car crash
and fought
nah and it was actually in manny swear
yeah yeah so i was living in yeah yeah
we recorded it while we didn't pod we'd
finish recording no way i was driving
home
um in the evening
and uh as i'm driving home i saw
a car
had smashed into like a bollard
so the bot it was like wrapped around
the bollard
and cars were just driving past there
was no police car next to it nothing it
was rich wrap around this bollard and i
drove past it the first time
and i just saw everyone acting normal
and i could see it there
and i was like
nah i couldn't see if anyone was in it
or not and i was like it would have been
dark in it yeah and i was thinking bro
why is there no police cars why is there
nothing here if like
does anyone know that this is a thing
like is there someone like [ __ ] in
there so i did spin around i went round
and came back again and then like pulled
up next to it and there was no one in
there and there's no one even anywhere
near it so i was like okay fair enough i
just fought tough enough too fair play
man good thing that's the only time
where i thought like big man i need to
do something um
but like i said in that situation no one
else stopped
any other situation where i've seen a
crash car i just drive from it's just a
normal thing that you see every day yeah
so literally yeah if he didn't look
because he looked and saw it and just
kept driving and he looked when he
looked again as we saw the u on top of
the car
bro and then saw the maya man getting
hit by the other car and only once a
year once it only pulled over he saw the
main man getting hit by another car and
[ __ ] off into the distance
crazy all to heaven today
how does he know that that's what they
said
um the
this is way after this is days after
okay so they've had interviews and
they've probably interviewed the kids
and okay everything like that so
um apparently there's a lot of domestic
violence in the house
they've interviewed like the aunties and
all this stuff so they know about the
history of like the dad they know
obviously what like the domestic
violence and i'm assuming one of the
kids
said that when they got in the car daddy
said that we're all going to happen
today yeah i'm assuming that's what
happens wow do you know whether the guy
got caught or anything no i don't and
this was when recently recently like uh
like a week ago [ __ ] yeah yeah what's
going on bro what's going on what's been
going on true what has been going on
stuff like this has been happening
forever this wild man i wonder what the
tipper point is for some people
same i wouldn't want to i wouldn't want
to obviously be in that mental state but
i wonder what it is because i don't know
how you can be so sane to be so insane
in like a matter of a day
bro that's some that's very scary bro
terrifying bro imagine just snapping
like that i couldn't i honestly couldn't
i don't think i'm capable of it yeah i
found my journey
capable of that i got the energy for
that 100 orchestrate that yeah that's um
that's um
[Music]
but yeah that's nuts bro i'm speechless
yeah he's going to hell there i don't
know where he thought he was going
heaven yeah he got it [ __ ] up
nah bro
you're gonna burn you're burning you're
to be sucking satan's tool
forever you're burning brother wow
that's oh jesus christ yeah fam it's
it's long
[ __ ] um
but anyway i have a uh
like a dilemma that i would like to read
hit me i feel like we haven't done one
of these in a minute
okay so man said hello
me and my girl love the podcast
brackets i fully got her hooked on it
plug in yourself
i actually had a dilemma i wanted to ask
you guys
me and my girl are planning on going to
the same unity oh god all right cool
right this is aimed at you again
me and my goal
planning on going to the same uni
together but i don't know how to tell my
parents
as we're planning on living together to
save money
she doesn't really have to worry about
talking to her parents as she's older
and has her own yard now
my problem is my dad
um
my problem is my dad
mainly
as he's nigerian
my mom in spanish is a bit more laid
back
but still was a bit wary with uh the
whole what if you break up situation
with my daddy in nigeria and i'm scared
of even telling him given the reaction
he might give me and once he sets his
mind on it i know he won't even consider
it
you must stubborn fam
[ __ ] stubborn so what should i do
should i go and not tell them or tell
them and deal with the outcome
i mean
it's like he's going to uni
he wants to live with his girl yeah to
save pee yep and he's scared to tell his
rents
yep story short long story short is
scared to tell his parents
uh because yeah his dad's nigerian and
once he tells his dad he knows he's
gonna get it in his head and just refuse
it off the bat i mean
i must say and he said she's old and
she's got her own spot she's got her own
spot she's a bit older so she doesn't
have to worry about sending her parents
um
okay i understand where
he thinks his mindset is
but i also understand
that his parents are probably right
in the sense that
the mum said um
the mom said i'll wait if you break up
yeah very understandable yeah i'm
assuming going to uni he's 18. i'm just
going to assume
um
you're
living with someone
especially a partner at such a young age
which i've never done
sounds like a mistake to me
especially in uni sounds like a big
mistake to me
um but then in the sense of your pops
him being stubborn and things i think
the reason why
he's more stubborn is because he's
straight to the [ __ ] point your mom's
clearly dilly-dallying about thinking oh
maybe this um
you know but
i think and ultimately both parents are
right that i don't think that's a
i don't think it's the best idea it
might be a great idea financially
but i think in the long term it's it's
gonna end in tears bro i think it's
terrible
cool you do realize he didn't ask if we
thought it was a good idea or not he
asked how he's going to deal with his
parents
very valid
man's doing it anyway he's doing it
regardless okay
how is he going to tell his parents man
he's he's clearly going to have to
he's obviously going to do it and then
tell his parents after i think that's
that's the only option he's going to do
and then tell his parents after but
how he's going to tell him
fam
you know one of them ones where you know
you're in trouble
and like i've i've gotten
back in the day like secondary school
like primary school you get like report
cards and [ __ ] when you fail stuff yeah
yeah yeah so i remember
it had to get signed to make sure your
parents are aware that you big man
you've been failing i don't want your
parents yeah yeah yeah so what i did was
i think i cut up
the top part that explained everything
it had a signature thing at the bottom
and a day and i was like
pops this is a
this is a um
this is a slip you have to sign for a
trip that i don't want to go to so you
have to sign if you don't want to go on
a trip you signed it don't know how i
patent that live from i don't know how
you panic never got clocked and i get i
went back into school gave them the ting
so it's cut up
cam i don't know i can't remember the
repercussions but i remember that that's
what i did yeah yeah yeah so it's
probably gonna have to be one of them
things where you're gonna have to
orchestrate some form of
big man i'm good guys i'm going to uni
i'm living in this block in halls or
whatever
and if they say oh they want to come try
and visit
you have to patent a fake yard thing
yeah yeah you have to pattern the
pattern of faith
i don't know
you've got to have obviously make
friends explain the situation to one of
your boys that you that you eventually
meet in you and be like boom in a couple
months time my parents are going to come
through i need you to
sell this yard to them like it's hours
yeah yeah
hours
they could never find out i'm staying
with shanice yeah they can't find out
they can't find out for the love of god
i'll be chucked out they can't find out
yay
you know what's wild to me
what's wild to me
is that
parents like i
i'm fortunate that i never i never grew
up with that that level of threat
yeah do i mean like when i well
obviously once i reached a certain age
like obviously i wasn't a bad kid so i
never had to deal with when i was young
young i never to deal with any of that
yeah and when i got older
again really i never had to deal with
any other
i want to do this with my parents it was
more like
if you want to do it do it you could do
it like whatever the repercussions if i
said like like even when i told my mom
and dad like oh i'm gonna be working as
like a guy that gets naked for a living
like even then they're so cool
like i actually don't think i ever told
my parents i was actually a butler in
the buff i think i told him i was just
uh
i can't remember i definitely didn't
tell him that i i don't know why i said
it i i won million percent until among
that yeah one million one million
percent or they would have gone mad i
don't think
i'm assuming they may have gone mad but
i just don't think it would have been a
conversation i wanted to have oh yeah
definitely not you know i remember
telling my parents because my only
because my mom was on me to be getting a
job
and i was like yeah cool well i finally
got jobs to leave it and i also think
sorry to cut you off about this whole
original story but i also think the
reason why i didn't tell him is because
i think
i
think when we were doing bottom brother
was i working at harsh as well or like
doing something else no no it was just
that you didn't start working to hush
until after i'd left butter in the buff
okay say that more than i can't remember
why i said to them but anyway back to
the point yeah so
um
oh [ __ ] hell um yeah i never had to
deal with that level of threat in that
if i was to go to my mum
and say like oh mum i want to go live
with
x at uni for her to be like no i don't
want you to do that and for me to be
like okay i understand that but i'm
going to do it anyway for her to come
back and be like cool well you won't
have your to come back to when you're
done with uni then like i've never had
to deal with that level of like i'm
doing this no you're not yes i am
cool well you don't have a family
anymore yeah so don't try it i've never
had to deal with that um so whenever you
like tell me stories or any of you man
tell me stories or any of my friends
tell me stories and stuff like that or
when i deal with this guy when he's like
my dad's nigerian he's just not gonna
have it yeah yeah yeah and like for me a
lot of times it's like yeah but who
gives a [ __ ] if your dad has it yeah but
then i realized like oh man we'll fully
kick you
out i'm like
what
that's crazy to me bro
because of what you want to do at uni
that's nothing to do with the house i
would live with my girlfriend at uni no
would you mean no it has nothing to do
with you i just said no but i'm doing it
anyway you ain't got yard anymore and
you ain't got money in your bank how
about that you want to live with chinese
stay there that's all they'll say don't
say stay there that's all they'll do no
i'm just not fair i'm an adult let me do
what i want to do are you
are you
yeah i don't yeah nah
fam you man go through it you think you
pay these bills you might go through it
broski
every other message is nigerian-ness
[ __ ] ridiculous bro it's the life we
live oh
the game is the game man this is the
game guys we rolled [ __ ] no um
right in terms of advice yeah
it sounds like food got it right you
need to pat in a fake yard you have to
pat in a fake sign people lie about
[ __ ] uni all the time all the time
bro all the time i am
i remember when i first got to uni same
again see my mom was on about jobs bro
oh my god she was on my back about jobs
when i left at home she was on my back
every summer i came back i had to get
jobs and my mom's on it about jobs i've
got an itchiest nose of all time oh my
god sorry
um she was honoring me about jobs all
the [ __ ] time and i remember when i
got to uni she was honoring me and i
lied and i was like bro i've dropped my
cv off to 2 000 places i remember you
said this on here before as well bro i
dropped my see i said it's hard i've
dropped my cv off i think i dropped my
cv off like three places yeah that's
like i'm not bad it's first year this is
my blue ink days isn't it yeah you got a
drop of blue ink like that like that i
remember i intentionally didn't tell her
that you got a job so i'm not dealing
with it i just can't be bothered man of
course the thing is it's like
ugh
i don't want one
and there was nothing about your work at
blueing that intrigued me of course not
until you said you had like a christmas
party or something and then i was a bit
like oh
you man came saying i didn't come
i didn't come where was it at
um lava ignite went up a hundred percent
i think i didn't come oh rem was there
for sure someone was there because right
now they're telling me i remember you
telling me about it rem was there for
sure yeah i'm surprised i thought you
were there
i missed all the cool [ __ ] okay okay
you're probably
yeah yeah i remember um so yeah yeah
i uh yeah i didn't come but i remember
you telling me like oh yeah we had a
christmas party and stuff like that and
i remember thinking [ __ ] that sounds fun
that's the only slither of anything to
do with you working that appealed to me
yeah was the christmas party apart from
that i was like [ __ ] that bro i mean you
said you got a shift at whatever time
[ __ ] that man [ __ ] that i remember
i think i remember one night um this was
the this was the first year of uni
working in blue ink i
watched um
the first time i'd watched paranormal
activity the first one scared the life
out of me yeah scared the living yeah
yeah yeah i could not sleep this was
what two thousand when did we start you
in 2009
18 fresh 18 yeah yeah yeah
could not see it was better if i seen
one i can't remember whose roommate was
in bear was watching it paranormal
activity couldn't sleep and i think i
had a
probably like a 10-6 that day
fam i stayed up bro and probably kept
for like two hours because i i was like
looking around bro
looking around for hours i was a ghost
on a shift nah i wanted to sleep at
every opportunity ten six seven stupid
like that i knew it was an early shift
and i finished like mid-evening oh
i don't know how i'm gonna do it bro i
don't know where i'm gonna do it
i think the only proper job i had it
wasn't even a proper job so what jobs
did i have at uni i bought those in a
buff
i had you had hush i didn't work a hard
shot sorry the hub i went to the hub
yeah and i went to mars and spencers i
don't remember that christmas tempting
it was dead i don't remember master
spencer was the only like proper job
working at the hub obviously got sacked
we went over that yeah um but working on
masterpieces were christmas tempting i
needed the money
and um
i remember
working there and they made me work on
the till
in the [ __ ] women's department
do you know how many clothes women
return fam
giving the idea how many clothes women
return
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
it is
stupid
half the [ __ ] i was dealing with was
returns oh wow i don't think you men are
taking the piss and then sometimes if i
wasn't on the till they're just making
me they just pay you for dumb [ __ ]
they're like i'll do you have one day
where you just like you just make sure
[ __ ] is neat
you just walk around
and you just move like a a rail like
that and he was walking around trying to
look busy for hours and hours off food
it was [ __ ] brutal i know bro it was
brutal man and i remember there was one
don that went to our you he was in our
year i didn't know him until we started
working there okay but he will give me
lifts he was cool but he got to work in
the cafe so when you when you actually
got the job that for the christmas time
job there was no assigned you didn't
apply for a certain all right
it was just like work you and then once
once you got the job
delegated and he remember he got to work
in the cafe it sounded sick bro i'm not
gonna lie it sounded sick and i was just
thinking [ __ ] he sounded like he just
had so much fun all the time and i was
just saying that down there to folding
clothes and moving little [ __ ] racks
and [ __ ] like that and i remember i had
to work on boxing day
at 5 00 a.m tough
5 a.m on boxing day started january
sales was on boxing day which meant i
had to spend christmas alone in
commentary
because i have to get up for work at
five the next day i remember this bro it
was a nightmare
it was a nightmare first year
no no no no no this was
grafton third year really
third year i do not remember this yeah
bro and i used to have to get the and it
was the [ __ ] marxist and spencer's at
the um
at the arena at the recovery arena i
think the bus there nah
bro
it was [ __ ] i hated it there did that i
hated it but i knew i couldn't get
sacked yeah i knew i couldn't get sacked
i just couldn't i can't remember what
situation i was in my life but i
couldn't i couldn't let my mom know i
got sacked i just couldn't and i had to
work there and i remember getting there
on the boxing day i think actually no
because it was a christmas stamp job i
think the boxing day was my last ever
shift there okay
well even if it wasn't planned it
definitely was my last year i didn't go
back after that i didn't go back after
that yeah um
but bro i remember
waking up i remember being there and
because the heating hadn't been on in
our yard
for the whole
christmas break which at uni is like a
month
the whole heat the heating hadn't been
on in weeks bro so when i got in the
yard
[ __ ] freezing three-story yard yeah
no one's been in there for weeks
dead of december mid-december
sorry bro bro [ __ ] freeze you can
imagine [ __ ] kidding
no food in the gaffe
all shops closed all shops closed bro
[ __ ] freezing wow
freezing
and i was just thinking this ain't life
and that was my first ever like real
[ __ ] job experience not a [ __ ] job
experience but like i had other jobs
before that like i'd even work in houses
warehouses before that and i'm working
it but that was like
one of the first like experiences where
i was like
wow
just the concept of having a job of [ __ ]
yeah like just the fact that someone's
going to tell me you need to be here at
5am tomorrow just that alone
to me was like this is baffling to me
yeah that's far fetched why yeah why do
i need to be there yeah at five o'clock
in the morning and i remember when i got
there for my shift
some [ __ ] asked me to do some [ __ ] and
i was doing it and then like five
minutes later it was like a two-hour job
she came about five minutes later are
you not done yet and i was like excuse
me
i never even met her before and i've
been working for like a month yeah he's
like you're not [ __ ] done yet and i
was like
it's five in the morning i'm thinking
i'm walking out i remember every half an
hour i was like i'm walking out i'm
walking out i'm not making it to the end
of this shift i'm walking out
i figured i was livid i can imagine i
was living i could imagine
that's like hell [ __ ]
hated it there that sounds like hell bro
absolutely hell bro
it was so [ __ ] christmas temp they use
and abuse christmas temps bro
no one remembered my name they didn't
give up the whole time i was there no
one remember no and you think you've got
a job now you think you're secure now
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
hurry up and get out
bro oh i hated it there jesus i
seriously how i made it through the
whole contract yeah i don't know
i don't know i'm pretty sure i was
supposed to come back after boxing day
but definitely didn't
i definitely didn't i remember were you
doing anyone staying in that yard did we
all go back yard like to hour y'all
respective yards and you were staying
yeah everyone back to london birmingham
whatever i came back
i spent christmas morning with my family
then came back to coventry
for christmas evening um i did bring
obviously i did bring my girlfriend at
the time okay
but we came back to the yard freezing
cold no food no food went to bed
freezing cold and when my alarm went off
in the morning big man i don't know how
i got out of bed
freezing cold and i remember thinking
i'm done
like your light goes off in your head
you're like
i'm done
i'm
not going and you can't
make me
i was definitely late because i was
thinking
oh because i remember i bought my car i
drove back okay i drove back that time
okay okay so i didn't have to get the
bus the next day so i could really
stretch it yeah yeah yeah and now i'm
done i'm not coming i'm not doing this
today
oh my long enough for like four and i
was like nah
four o'clock on boxing day
wow human beings shouldn't have to be
treated like that
and this is just a normal retail job
i don't know how people are doing it bro
i don't know retail and
retail especially for like christmas
time so like black fridays all that is
hell on earth bro and hospitality
obviously for like christmas periods no
on uh nah fam hell on earth it was an
absolute nightmare i remember had one
[ __ ] try and return like
tights that she bought like a year ago
mugging it and she didn't even have to
receive mugging it
i was like girl
[Laughter]
sharon gao get out
get out
bro
i really this is a message to anyone who
works retail i'm so
sorry [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
that
get out now you
leave while you can bro bro
leave
go now get out
it's horrible there oh bro i've done
both sides well i've been a hospitality
and i've been in retail
all of you man escape it's tough escape
start a bakery or something do something
else get out of there
because it's hell
it is oh
fam i'm so sorry
it's not on it really wasn't mum it's
not it's tough it's very tough
[ __ ]
anyway i hope you answered your question
anyway yeah bro you gotta lie you have
to you wanna keep everyone happy you
gotta lie man afterlife but yeah
celebi right guys love love love love
love love
see you on thursday
[Music]